en promesas básicamente comenzamos con
el acuerdo entre el mercosur y la Unión
Europea que comenzó a ser discutido en
1999 20 años después se aprueba pero se
queda en poder de los países miembros y
se queda bloqueado incluso por la
posición del expresidente sobre la
amazonia hoy ha sido un momento que
podríamos definir histórico porque
vanderline ha dicho que pretende aprobar
este acuerdo para finales de este año lo
que podría parecer una buena noticia sin
embargo Lula el presidente de Brasil ha
criticado dos aspectos por un lado las
sanciones que prevé este acuerdo y al
mismo tiempo
ha recordado también que ha recordado
también que
hay unas series de sanciones previstas
contra el agronegocio O sea que los
centrales o sea los obstáculos que pone
el gobierno de
europea se deben también a eso después
ha habido otra promesa muy importante
dos mil millones de dólares para que el
gobierno de Brasil convierta su economía
en una economía verde se ha recordado
que Lula quiere acabar con la
deforestación para el año 2030 sin
embargo Lula viene sufriendo reveses en
el parlamento porque la base del
gobierno no ha conseguido aprobar el
programa de gobierno y la oposición ha
quitado competencias importantes tanto
del Ministerio del medio ambiente como
el de pueblos indígenas que ha sido
creado este año Entonces por un lado el
gobierno de la Unión Europea quiere que
los indígenas estén en el centro de la
política Ambiental de Lula sin embargo
no le dejan aquí en su propia casa en el
parlamento
los ladrones que están intentando vaciar
de contenido estos dos
ministerios Entonces es un día positivo
sin embargo la letra pequeña nos sugiere
que no va a ser tan fácil